she too I uh you don't speak Romania
you don't like no it's lovely
there's this guy that lives across the
street and he's always looking over here
looking over here how
every time I look over there he's just
staring right at me
Hello darling any reason in particular
you're standing in the dark
do you feel like coming in for a drink
yeah have you noticed anyone watching
you in your apartment no
this guy has been watching us since we
moved in
maybe he's staring at the woman who's
staring at him
what's happening
they found a woman murdered in her
apartment they're saying the woman had
her head cut off
the man at the movie theater followed me
into this
followed you
that's him
I need to know for myself that he's been
following me
sometimes I just look at people just
tell me what you want me to want you to
believe me
I heard screaming from in here okay just
open the door please
but no one has really noticed before
[Music]
foreign